(swooshing sound)
(bang)
- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today we're talking about how to make
a good first impression.
Rule number two is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And also as you're watchin' if you
hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put it in quotes so other people
can be inspired as well, and when you
write something down
yourself it's much more
likely to stick for you as well.
Enjoy.
(bright music)
(techno music)
- A friend of mine a little
ways back was at a company.
It was a finance company.
And he was presenting
to the head honcho boss.
This guy's worth a
hundred million dollars,
flies around in private jets,
and was generally an
abuser, like he was verbally
abusive to everybody in the office.
So he's got this meeting
and he's pitching to him
whether or not they should invest
in a company they gave him to research.
And gets around to the end and he says,
so, based on all my research I think
that this company is a
pass, it's just too risky.
Head honcho guy, David,
stands up, looks at him,
the rest of the team and says,
You guys are pussies.
Everyone else there gets quiet
because they've taken
this kind of abuse before.
But my friend is not used to this, right.
He's never been treated like this.
So he looks right back
at the boss and says,
David, where I come
from calling another man
a pussy is the worst thing you could do.
You would immediately start a fist fight.
Don't ever call me a pussy again.
Then he gets quiet.
And everyone in the room gets quiet.
And David gets quiet.
A few seconds pass.
And I'm sure they must
have seemed like eternity,
and David says, I'm sorry,
I won't ever do that again.
Completely goes back,
meeting starts rollin'
people pick up the slack.
But what happened is after that,
my friend never, ever
received that kind of abuse
that people in the office
continued to get from him.
Right that guy never
gave him any crap again.
It's because he set a boundary.
And even though he was low man
on the totem pole, he created respect.
This is what happens,
when people cross lines,
I'm not saying you that you
need to shout their faces off.
Neither am I saying you need
to do what most people do
and go he he, you know, it's okay.
I've seen people do this in
so many situations, right.
Somebody makes a racist, a sexist comment
that they don't like,
in a business meeting
somebody shows up really late,
doesn't respect your time.
Or I know a girl in a business meeting,
she was basically being hit on by the guy
and didn't know what to do so
she just kind of laughed it off,
pretended that it was just a joke.
In these scenarios what you need to do,
in so many words is say
one, hey, I don't appreciate
what you just did, and two
don't ever do it again.
And then quiet, that is it.
I'm not asking you to yell at someone.
I'm not asking you to take it home.
I'm not asking you to complain
about it with your friends.
If you do this you will
find that the boundaries
you set create more respect
in all of your interactions.
Incredibly powerful.
(bang)
- I can probably get somebody to consume
something from me within
the first 13 seconds
let alone 30 seconds because
it's not what I'm going to say.
It's how I feel.
See words are great, but
energy's a whole different game.
And I win on that game, right.
And so within the first 30 seconds
I'm going to establish and
have always established
for my entire life from first grade,
first 30 seconds into any business meeting
to when I'm in a big off site
when everybody goes around the room,
I'm Stefan I work at Vander Media.
But then I do my, I'm
Gary, I'm a Jets fan.
Like, I within 30 seconds set the tone
vibe wise if I don't get to say something,
which is rare for me not to say something
within the first 30 seconds.
I establish that I'm different.
Yeah, I'm different.
- I don't want you to forget
that first impressions
have nothing to do with you,
as much as they have to
do with the other person.
And I know you know that as well.
But how present do you
really get for other people?
You know think about the
last time you were with
your partner, your spouse, your lover,
the person you're in an
intimate relationship
with if you are, I mean, how present
have you really been with them at dinner?
How present are you with them
when you're walking in the door?
How present are you with them in general?
Because that level of presence
is probably what you're carrying
into the social world too.
And I want you to remember that if you
really want to make a difference
and you really want to make an impact
or a great quote,
unquote first impression.
It comes from being
present with other people,
and truly listening, being engaged,
and interested in who they are,
what they're about, what's
going on in their world.
Part of having, being
great at first impressions
is asking questions of other people.
And genuinely meaning them.
Not read, yeah I read these are the five
great questions to ask
at a networking event.
It makes you another ass who's
asking those five questions.
Go ask questions that are real for you.
Like if you meet somebody ask them
questions that are authentic for you.
That's it, do it with
what you're interested in.
Tell people, hey I'm interested in this.
How do you perceive it?
What do you do?
Learn from them.
Don't be so focused on bragging
about yourself to make a first impression.
Instead learn enough about someone
so that you can brag about
them to the next guy.
Meaning if now, you're
talking with somebody
and you learn something about them.
Someone walks up, be like, hey,
what's your name, oh, Pete, hey Pete
this is Barbara, Barbara's awesome,
she was just telling
me how she's like this.
And now you're just braggin' up on Barbara
versus worrying about
braggin' about yourself.
And in that situation you will
be the person of influence.
- You've heard it said that you never get
a second chance to make
a good first impression.
The fact is that when
you first meet a person
he makes a judgment about you
in approximately four seconds.
And his judgment is finalized
largely within 30 seconds
of the initial contact.
In a survey of the members
of the American Personnel
Association those men and
women who are responsible
for hiring people for large companies.
Members generally agreed
that they made their decision
to hire or not to hire a person
within 30 seconds of the first meeting.
So everything contributing
to the way you look
on the outside is important.
If it's not helping you, it's hurting you.
While you cannot control
your physical features
you have total control over
your dress and grooming.
In fact, we generally assume that a person
consciously and deliberately
makes a personal statement
about himself with every
part of his appearance,
that he can affect in any way.
You're clothes are responsible
for 95% of the first impression
that you make on someone
because in most instances
your clothes cover 95% of your body.
Your grooming, your
hairstyle, and the other
ways that you can
determine your appearance
from the neck up also exert
an inordinate influence
on the way that you are perceived.
On your ethos with someone else.
Your accessories, such
as purse or briefcase,
watch, tie, rings, pens and other elements
all make a statement that will or will not
help to put you in a position
to influence another person.
- And last but certainly not least
is something that I do that I,
it's a little trick, alright
It's like first impression espionage.
Because there's no gettin'
around likin' somebody
when they actually give you a compliment.
When I meet somebody for the first time
I try to look for something that
I can compliment them on, alright.
Because automatically you compliment 'em
they like you more, it happens right.
Because when somebody
gives you a compliment,
you're like yeah, you just like 'em more.
It works gentlemen.
And then when they think of you next time,
they're going to think that you that dude
that gave 'em the compliment
that they automatically like.
Gentlemen here is the deal.
First impressions, we only
have one chance to make it.
So make yours count.
(swooshing sound)
- So I have maybe a different perspective
on making a good first impression?
I think the best first impression
that you can make is when you are feeling
confident in yourself.
I'm reminded of the clip
between Jay z and Warren Buffet
where they ask Jay z if
you ever feel uncomfortable
going into these business board rooms.
Cause he wasn't, he's not
from the business school.
He didn't go to, you
know, business university.
And he said I'm always comfortable
going into any room because I like me.
And he didn't to university but he
went to the school of life and as long
as he's confident in
himself then he carries that
throughout any situation that he's in.
And all he has to do is
not try to be somebody else
but just try to be himself
and that allows him to win.
I think if you embrace that philosophy,
it's not about how firm your handshake is,
or what clothes you're wearing,
or what the first word
out of your mouth is,
at the end of the day for me,
it's about your own mindset,
you're own confidence,
you're own, not like
confidence boasting big ego,
but just feeling self confident
and happy as a human being.
If you carry that into every
situation that you're in
you'll make a great first impression.
As an example, I think back of my
entrepreneurial career,
when if first started
meeting with entrepreneurs
I always had a suit on,
full on suit.
When I'd be working I'd be
in a hoodie or whatever,
something else, but then
when I had a meeting
it would always be full on suit.
I'd have one kind of sittin' at the office
waitin' for me whenever
I had that meeting.
Cause I felt like to make
that good first impression
I needed to wear a suit.
And if you go back to
some of my first videos,
if you look at like the Walt Disney video
or some of the earlier ones you'll see
that I'm in a suit, and I
was so uncomfortable in it.
But I thought I had to look the part.
And slowly as I evolved
I went from the suit
to just a blazer, to business casual,
to now the point where
I'm basically always
wearing a hoodie or a t-shirt.
This is how I'm naturally,
this is how I'm most comfortable.
When I go to events and I'm asked
to give out awards, and
it's a black tie event,
I'm still wearing my hoodie,
and I wear some slacks, some
black pants and some shoes.
Cause it's who I am.
And I'm super comfortable
in that environment.
And so even thought the people
might be wearing tuxedos, I'm happy
with who I am and what I'm wearing.
And so I think that transition for me
has really helped in that as long as you
are comfortable in your own skin,
then you can make the
situation be a positive one.
That if I show up in a
suit that I'm not confident
then I'm not going to make
a good first impression.
But if I show up in a
hoodie, and I am confident,
then I'm going to make
a good first impression.
I've had some comments on the channel
where people said hey if you wore a suit
you'd have more views, I'd
take you more seriously.
It wouldn't help me.
If I was wearin' a suit
and I was uncomfortable
gettin' out in front of the camera,
it would not help me get more views.
It wouldn't help me achieve my mission.
So I think the ultimate thing
is you being happy with yourself
you find the self confidence to understand
this is what you're all about
then you can be amazing
in every situation.
Be yourself in every situation,
and if you can walk into a room like that,
you'll notice that you walk
in with your chest higher.
Not because it's a strategy,
not because you're walkin' in sayin'
I need to have my chest high,
I need to, I need to, I need to be,
you know, I got to, I'm
wearing my power suit,
this is what I've got on here.
Not because you're psyching yourself up,
just because you are
actually self confident.
That's what people will gravitate to.
And that's how you make
a great first impression.
(swooshing sound)
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video
because Ivan asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Belief Life
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did you take from this video
that you will immediately apply somehow
in your life or your business.
What did you think about my story
about making a first impression?
Do you have something
that you want to share
that could add to this video and help
the other members of Believe Nation?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Ashley.
Ashley thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.
(swooshing sound)
(bang)
- How can you make that all important
first impression count to set the tone
for the relationship that follows
and the potential business
that can result from it.
My advice would be to tell them a story.
It doesn't have to be War and Peace,
and it shouldn't be.
But stories spark interest,
keep people engaged
and help them to understand.
Stories allow the conscious mind to relax.
But at the same time
the pattern perceiving,
unconscious mind can make the match
and use the story to help
them connect with you.
Too often in business we try and connect
with people on a rational level.
But this isn't enough to inspire
and influence them to take
action for your cause.
Let me break it down into the three ways
people tend to answer the question
and give you some examples.
The first answer that most people
give is the standard answer.
That you will have heard,
I may well have said, many times.
What do you do?
I'm an accountant.
Whether or not people actually understand
what you do they think
they know what you do.
And so they switch off.
They've met loads of accountants
who have all given the same answer.
They very rarely follow
up with a question.
And if they do it's often out of pity
rather than genuine curiosity.
And I'm picking on accountants here,
but it's the same if
you answer's solicitor,
web developer, florist or magician.
People have a good idea of what you do
and no connection is made.
So it's the next thing you
can do to grab their attention
and create some curiosity in them.
You could reply, I help people
save money on their taxes,
or I take the hassle away from people
when it comes to their business finances.
That's certainly a better answer
than the first response
of I'm an accountant.
And it shows them that
you can solve a problem
that many businesses face.
It also creates a little bit
of curiosity, but barely.
If you wish to answer like this
try and make your answer
a little more memorable.
Try and inject some humor to make
your great first impression.
A friend of mine introduces himself
as a crime fighting space man.
It gets a laugh every time and always
invites the question well
what do you mean by that?
This gives him the opportunity to talk
a little bit about his
architectural practice
where he redesigns buildings
that are regularly the
victim of break-ins.
It's a great introduction
and is sure to be remembered.
But it's not enough to make that lasting
connection on a subconscious level.
So, here's the third way, and the best way
to answer the question what do you do?
Incorporate a story.
A friend of mine, whenever
he is asked this question,
tells this story,
growing up, both of his parents
owned their own businesses,
and were never in control
of their finances.
This meant that every January
there would be panic in his house
and many nasty surprises that resulted
in a lot of unpleasantness,
arguments, and canceled plans.
Because of this he's
grown up hating surprises,
and has dedicated his life to ensuring
that other business owners never get
nasty surprises when it
comes to their finances.
So what does he do?
He's an accountant.
Now imagine you're networking
and you've heard the
answer I'm an accountant
seven or eight times and
then you hear this story.
Which accountant are you
going to pass your work to?
That's right.
The one that hates surprises.
He's made a connection with you,
and you'll also find it easy to refer
to friends and business associates.
Notice that step two invites a question
to which the answer is step one.
And that step three includes
step two and step one.
It's important to include all three steps
but it must be done in this order
to grab the attention, generate curiosity,
keep them hooked and make the connection.
- Number two is body language.
How you walk, how you stand, alright.
Are you in an open posture,
or are you arms crossed
and lookin' pissed?
Guys the way that you carry yourself
and the non verbal
communication that you're doing
with your body is critical and essential
to that first impression.
Eye contact, smile, handshake,
all these things play a factor.
And if you're fallin' down or lacking
in one of these areas
it's going to reek havoc
on those first impressions, all of 'em.
- Fake it, til you make it,
is often misinterpreted and it's a great
piece of advice, don't get me wrong.
But fake it til you make it applies only
to body language and non
verbal communication.
When you start using
fake it til you make it
in the things that you say,
that's when you run into trouble.
So for instance, the CEO,
who had a terrible quarter
speaking in front of his company
gets up there and says, hey guys,
we're doing great, you know, not exactly
where we want, but this is really on track
and we, our numbers were kind of off
in the projections, so
we're killin' it right now.
Or right, guy at a networking event
who goes off and pretends that he has
a kind of status at his company
that he can hook people up,
he goes, you know, I'm in,
just send me your resume
I'll get you a job no problem.
And he's got no such power.
This happens all the time.
People fake power that they don't have.
Or a guy who wants to impress a girl
takes her to a nice
restaurant, really great.
But rather than acting like, you know,
this is a special occasion,
pretends this is something
he does all the time.
That kind of stuff does not fly.
So here's what you want to do.
Fake it til you make it
in the way that you speak
and the way that you carry yourself,
your tonality, the way
that you gesticulate,
the way that you breathe, that's
going to affect your head,
which is going to actually
change the way that you feel.
Right, your physiology
does change your emotion.
And we've talked about this at length,
I don't want to go into it here but,
when it comes to the
things that are coming out
of your mouth be honest to a fault.
So for instance, that CEO,
might get up there and say, guys, listen,
this quarter was a disappointment.
We did not hit our numbers,
we didn't do the things
that we needed to do.
I've spoken to many of you,
I've reflected on what needs to happen
and here's how we're going
to do it going forward.
The confidence that he
speaks with is what's going
to inspire people to hang on, to continue.
And the honesty's going
to make them trust him,
that holy cow, we can do this,
he's not just going to
sugar coat everything.
Take the guy who takes a
woman to a nice restaurant,
right, rather than like going
in and being like oh yeah.
Pretending he knows the maitre'D,
or that this happens all the time,
or talking about his investment portfolio,
or whatever it is, he
might go in there and say,
listen I got to be honest,
this place is way nicer
than the restaurants
I normally go to, so I hope that
you're impressed by the food,
and that makes you laugh
extra hard at my jokes.
Right, play off fun, funny.
But you can let people
know this is special.
This is nice.
That honesty is going to let her her know,
which is a huge concern
for women by the way
that they men that they're dating
are not being real, are not being honest.
when you show things that
might not be to your favor,
right, and you're not doing
it in a calculated way.
but you're doing it because it's honest.
that's going to create, create
a bond of trust between you
that is actually going
to make the relationship
go much, much better.
(swooshing sound)